you guys covered some of it already yeah
so we talked about this kim kardashian
and then we talked about no one knows
for sure though what do you mean
nothing's final it's all hearsay yeah
it's all hearsay but
we've kind of been hearing this for a
while
that's true yeah you guys pretty much
talked about this already it's only what
the media tells us right so we don't
know
yeah i want to go i want to know where
does kim go from here
right she went from all the athletes in
the back but all the rappers and
athletes right do you think it's time to
try a white guy
i was alluding i was a loser struck out
a few times with the black man do you
think you'd give a white man a chance
at this point or armenian armenian
i was alluding to that but not we're
good
it's just not the right it's not really
calling it like it is just not
well she did have a white guy the guy
who played for the nets he was an
[ __ ] oh
no he wasn't white he was mixed
christian
no we don't claim chris well he's stuck
in the middle yeah
he's not purgatory right now you said
try white
yeah i tried watching christopher yeah
they even had a wedding and [ __ ]
look oh damien these are people assuming
who she's going to date
no no no no she's been whipped oh yeah
ray j was the first one
no no no nick cannon was whoa what the
hell
cincinnati's finest let's go dude that
was a
hot second oh it was yeah look at her
keep going
yeah she dated nick cannon i got it
nick cannon says that he dated kim
kardashian before ray j yeah
oh he was before like the one of the
first guys she's ever dated wow
she came back to him i remember that one
i liked them together i did yeah
bro bush's wife now with look just [ __ ]
she's
because she's also armenian yeah yeah
they're bothering me she's super
what brazilian wife is armenian yeah
current wife she looks just like him
yeah
she boxes bro uh she goes to the gym
that will be i train that
go to a boxing video chin she got hands
yeah she's super super right there look
at that yeah they have a cute kid too
man
i think a few of them right yeah she's
got a few kids with them oh
you should see man shout out to that man
wife now
she's a beast
that jab is [ __ ] solid
calm down
you want to give a compliment dude
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh that's a girl said that uh i think
she's a boxer right yeah it looks like
it she actually oh oh shoot
dang okay there's some other pictures of
her
oh she's a cop where's that acting oh
damn
i'm not a real clown oh oh okay okay
wait hey no haters
are gonna say i'm not a real cop hater
oh [ __ ] so she might be a cop oh she's a
cop
that's a box not bad looking either
just watching it yeah
there's some inner thighs
yeah she's pretty man oh yeah so i'll
take that comment back that jab was
[ __ ] what's your boxing you're right
girl that just that's a [ __ ] solid
jab
what is this i don't know i never missed
oh that's here
all right that's it all right yeah but
she's a shout out to ray j's girl though
yeah
shout out to that's what i mean no i
know not shout out to her i'm gonna try
and get back to brazil
christian ronaldo she dated him he would
fly her out and then he
kind of big-timed her really yeah she
was like a booty call for cristiano
right
how big miles austin i remember daddy
cowboy what's that
uh he played a wide receiver for the
dallas cowboys okay who was that who's
that michael capoon oh my god i liked
him as a kid
he was like sort of asian didn't he yeah
he's been like that's so raven right
yeah that's so rare he was like one of
my biggest crushes growing up
what's he do now though i don't know
when they were like
real young cause that doesn't count
he's still so fine goddamn he's fine
yeah
still yeah i think he's fine interesting
i told him he's actually really good
looking he's in scorpio he's half what
he's filipino white yeah that's
he was in power rangers well that might
be him now
oh he's so cute oh damn cat
chin said take it easy he was in scorpio
i
uh that was he's like a halle berry x
there it is yeah that scarf is intense
keep going he's at the lakers again
that's the one yeah it's so weird it was
he was on he was
getting they had they had a full-on
wedding right oh yeah they had a huge
wedding for
a 72-day marriage and then he got it
he got booed nonstop every time he went
in the games really yeah he did it
he came for this to the sons for a hot
second is it just because he
was with kim kardashian you just get
booed every time you touch the ball you
get booed yeah
oh that's so sad and a lot of he wasn't
a great player so i was like
yeah man i'm trying to get some work is
he still playing or not no i don't think
so
no he said like a lot of his teammates
didn't like him like because when he
showed up with him
cameras everywhere like man dude goddamn
oh just bringing a lot of
unwanted attention yeah yeah because
they made a whole like
series out of their wedding right i
think so yeah
yeah yeah that was a weird one
what is he doing now he's probably still
playing nah
tv shows oh he's on a tv show
but probably the reality is no just the
kardashians yes he's not an actor
so he doesn't play anymore oh he does
2017 was last year
oh prat took his money and invested it
damn he played for everybody yeah
personal life national team career what
is that
honorable 2002. oh he's uh he invested
in real estate and owned his uh
restaurant in minnesota
good for him congrats there you go yeah
invest your money man he can only go up
i'm learning
so kim has been with some wives she got
a catalogue
asians a lot of blacks
just a splash he's not
because filipinos are mixed with
spaniards already oh so it's like
half of that yeah yeah so you're kind of
like yeah divine like joe coy joe coy is
half
yeah oh wow looks super asian does he
really he has green eyes
he looks asian but yeah you think asian
that guy just looked like a mexican
that's fair chill on scorpion king man
i know yeah she's fine
she said that i said that with my heart
that's not how i describe that man she's
like he's funny it's fine you don't like
asian guys
i will yeah oh how about that when i get
off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son